i think my high school's into values and
morality
and all that and i don't have those
qualities
hello and welcome to the rest of your
teenage self podcast i am your
roast coming queen glinda in oakton high
school's 2007 performance of the wizard
of oz
elise morales and with us today i have
the extremely funny actor comedian you
know him
from mad tv you know him as a former
poway titan please welcome bobby lee
i'm so excited to have you thank you so
much for having me my friend
yeah so we um we were just discussing
how your high school has not yet
included you in their hall of fame yeah
because um
you know i have had some cool people go
to my high school
uh tom delong from blink182 that's
extremely cool all right and but the
thing is is that we're not in
the powie high school hall of fame
because
we don't have the kind of morality and
ethics
that they that they subscribe to they
don't even put in tom
well yeah i mean he has the same kind of
morality as i do all right he's not like
a better person than i am
no i know but i i just i mean and this
is
this is not to say you're iconic in many
many ways but i do
feel that blink 182 is like they're huge
yes i feel like you
have to acknowledge blink
it won't because it's like you know we
we're not christians or we're not like
you know your traditional like wholesome
kind of entertainer you know okay so
that actually gets me into
the first question that i like to ask
everyone because i feel like it sets the
sets the full tone for your high school
experience
was paw way high school public or
private power high school was a
public school and um i think the problem
with me though
is is i went in and out of that school
because of uh
yeah yeah yeah and for those for those
listening to the audio version
uh we we mimed we mimed a little snort
we mimed a little drink
and then and then yeah yeah and then
yeah
yeah i didn't want that at
all okay yeah yeah um so kicked out for
weed and [ __ ] yeah
i did all kinds of weird things in
school like i did
crystal meth at the age of 12 or 13.
i dropped a hundred hits of acid by the
time i was probably 16
i smoked weed every day and drank every
day so i was just kind of like one of
those types of guys
but i was also on the wrestling team and
tennis team
so it seems like you had like
a lot of different extracurriculars
going on some school sanctions
some not yeah yeah yeah what ended up
happening was though is that i um
i kept getting kicked out so i got
kicked out twice in high school
so and every time i got kicked out i
would end up in some sort of institution
or like a rehab of some sort
and i was always um in and out and i was
a really troubled
young man you know
did that affect your ability to graduate
like when you would go out
would you just effectively miss like
half the school year or were you
like responsible for school work
well that's a good question what
happened was um in my junior year i went
to
a rehab called the mcdonald center it
was in la jolla
was it related to the franchise the
mcdonald's
like was it a clown there or not like
i don't know they do charitable work
yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i never saw a clown or a
big mac or anything but um
could have been i don't know but um they
do stuff with kids i don't know man
yeah i was so high i probably wouldn't
even known but um
but what happened there was when i was
at the mcdonald center i met
a korean man his name was dan
because my father my father just died
but my father growing up was um
very abusive you know physically you
know he used to beat me with
golf clubs and beat up my mom it was
crazy
right and so i didn't really have a a
father figure so when i was in
the mcdonald's center my junior year i
met a guy by the name of dan
okay and dan was like this nazi
like sober guy and he saved my life he
he said you're gonna go to you're gonna
graduate
with all your classmates and i go yeah
but i've missed so much school and he
said
it doesn't matter i'm going to make you
take extra you know
like a zero period a lunch period every
so i graduated with
the rest of my classmates because i got
sober my junior year in high school
wow okay so you you
basically just he helped you like make
all of that time
up by getting rid of like any free time
you would have had
yeah i mean i just needed some sort of
direction i didn't have anyone to help
me and he
was kind of like you know i don't
believe in jesus but i believe in some
sort of spiritual i believe that he was
put into my life at that time
he was a very important um figure in my
life
he kind of um acted as if he was my
father and he
made me do all these things and i
graduated i got sober
on my junior year and um so my senior
year in high school
i was completely sober and completely
doing
the right things and i was able to
graduate on time that's incredible
that's like that's really amazing so
also you know you have this you have
this man dan who's acting as your father
figure during this time
what about like what about your friend
group like the people
your age were you like were your friends
as equally troubled maybe coming from
the same kind of thing as you or were
you like the bad boy
of the group my senior year i you know i
mean obviously i grew up in poway so i
reconnected with
friends that i had you know on and off i
guess
when i was younger and but i had
shadier friends when i was using drugs i
mean obviously that's always the case
you know you
yeah one group you know which was one
guy
his name was julio he was a he was him
and i just would drop acid and watch
like vietnam war movies
but then when i graduated i i um i
started hanging out with
the whites you know what i mean the
whites are good they're good people
yeah yeah yeah so the whites you know
whites
help me you know be getting yeah they're
in a finished basement
their dad's ordered pizza
a wholesome time yeah and i remember
like um
i just love white people because like i
would used to
like i would do sleepovers at like my
white friend's house and in the mornings
you could smell things that i guess like
you could smell like
coffee and you smell like maybe
a baseball glove like that leather like
they're just different kinds of smells
but if you woke up at my house you could
it smells like an okinawa fish market
like it smells different and yeah i hung
out with the whites of my senior year
and i graduated
and because i chased show business
for so long i kind of cut
ties with the kids that i grew up with
but almost like i always thought that i
had to hang out with
people that were super talented in
comedy you know
yeah ended up having just friends that
were
comedians and that were also very good
at what they do but that's not like
necessarily
the best pool of people i mean this is
not
a cross-section of society i mean you're
they make comics and people in the
entertainment business are homicidal and
yeah yeah questionable ethics you know
and so it's like now i'm getting to a
point where it's like why did i abandon
my high school friends and i i i don't
know how to link back up with them
you know obviously you were in
to some hardcore activities outside of
school but were you a troublemaker
inside of school
like or were you just kind of like
stoner kid in the back
not really causing any drugs no i was
like i was a little weird like i also
had a phase
and this is going to be so embarrassing
but i just i i've said it before but
i had a phase where i would like be at
like a party
and i would just suck guys dicks i'm not
okay i'm not gay
but like i would just do it you know
this is just something you were doing in
high school
yeah yeah when i was using like i would
just you know me just like
go out behind a bush and just suck a
kid's dick did
did other people at your school know
about it was it like a
party trick no it's private it's
embarrassing
i know but stuff like i don't know i
just feel like in high school
it's like such a small world like
everyone knew so many people's business
you were able to keep that like
a real secret listen in my school like
when i graduated like 10 years after
that there was a kid that
was able to wear a t-shirt at my school
saying that like
homosexual sin and and gays are an
abomination
and they would wear that shirt to school
and they were okay with it so it's like
that's the mentality of what where i
grew up you know i mean
so let's um let's pull up this picture
that you sent
let's take a look at the first uh the
first picture we have here
here we go okay
look how messy i am you are skinny
and let's talk about this look
we have on like a turtleneck we have on
like a a patterned vest i call it the
1970s
uh gay filipino magician
honestly this is the look like if they
did a porn version of the movie hook
i would play rufio yes yes
that is 100 correct so is this
picture when we're looking at is this
around the time where
we're secretly sucking dick like what's
going on
this is no stick this is post supposed
again so this is you truly have like an
angelic baby face in this photo and this
like
angelic baby face boy i'm looking at
right now has
already like tried every drug he's
dabbled in sucking dick for fun
yeah yeah i took this photo probably
when i was about
six months sober so you know i don't
look as
um ratchet yeah i don't know
what the [ __ ] that vest is like
it's like a russian rug i mean look at
that thing i was gonna say so is this
typical of your personal style because
i feel like this is bold for a high
school boy
yeah yeah i
had i always had a liberacy kind of vibe
yeah
i'm not doing that yeah i've always i
remember going to
because my mom would that year would be
well every year she would take me high
school clothes shopping
and i remember going to like weird
stores like i wouldn't go
to a traditional store where kids would
usually buy
clothes i'd go let's go to a thrift
store or
you know what i mean and i would weird
things you know
i would yeah i loved i wore
crazy clothes in high school that was
like my claim to fame is that i loved i
would wear like one
pink converse and one black one and then
like a pink sock and a black sock
like opposite so i would like to mix and
match everything and i'd wear like a
ball gown to school i was really
yeah trying to make a statement i was
eccentric in that way as
well so are you also dating during this
time like what's
your situation i think that i could
prove this but
i may not be able to but i think i was
the first
korean in cell in america
i really do man because i could not
really generally get
girls i mean the girls that i would
generally get i mean this is another
private thing but i've said it before um
you know in
earlier in my life i would have to do um
prostitutes so but that was in high
school
oh early on yeah i mean really you were
a kid
so it's like you weren't your brain
wasn't even
like the decision-making function wasn't
even fully there yet
yeah yeah when listen my life is this
okay
you know when i was a kid i had so much
trauma
living in a violent you know i mean
atmosphere yeah
that i did everything i could to feel
normal
right so you do drugs right i was also
molested as a young person too
and so it's like and sexually i would do
things to like um
you know to fix that hole inside of me i
had this emptiness inside me
now i'm doing everything i can to patch
those things up within me
health in a healthy way like i i have
trauma therapy
you know meetings you know i i'm sober
you know but you know i have to admit
you know comedy
to getting prostitutes and all that
stuff you know i mean
is all a result of i think living in the
kind of atmosphere that i grew up in
yeah yeah so did teenage
bobby realize the extent of how [ __ ]
up
his situation was or was that kind of
something you couldn't really process in
the moment because you had to just be
like
going to your day-to-day life i mean as
a kid you don't
even in high school you don't ever think
of it because you don't really you think
that that's that's your reality that's
your
that's your normal baseline right so
it's like
you don't really think about it until
later in life
it's funny you know i knew that i had to
do this um podcast with you
right and the part of me was like you
know
um a little nervous about it because you
know it is
that you know high school was you know a
very delicate
sensitive time for me you know yeah and
yeah
yeah and you know this is when you're
you know i don't know you're
discovering trying to discover who you
really are and you also have social
pressures and uh it's just and also
along with all my you know [ __ ] up
issues you know it was a dark time you
know
yeah so on the one hand you're dealing
with all of this
stuff that is so far outside of like the
normal high school experience you're
having this
like extremely traumatic private
situation that's going on with you at
home but are you also engaging in like
kind of the normal stuff of high school
like like you know you say you did the
play you're on the wrestling team like
is there also this other bobby that's
just like a normal teenager who like
flips that switch sometimes
yeah i mean you know i you know
obviously my freshman year i was on the
wrestling high school
and also tennis team in freshman year
then i went to a rehab
and then i wrestled until my junior year
and i went i just couldn't do it anymore
and then you know when i when i got
sober i i
went to prom you know i went to
homecoming i did all the things that you
needed to do
to i guess those experiences
especially when i was sober i was like i
should do them but it's not like if
i wanted to do it you know i mean i did
it because you know i
thought this is what everyone does you
know what i mean
yeah and i want to i want to keep up
with like the appearance that i'm living
a normal high school life
i'm not really in retrospect it it
they're not really they're no memories
from those events
do you remember like the biggest trouble
that you got into
at your school i mean i guess you were
kicked out but was it for like a
specific
incident no i mean i mean
there's just i can't go into detail but
um there was some criminality involved
with my using you know so
you know like um my cousin and i tried
to rob
a store and then yeah he went to
juvenile hall
and i i went i i escaped san diego and i
lived on the streets for about
almost a month you know what i mean so
this was also in high school
yeah yeah yeah yeah so you know i was
always like you know i was either in
wrestling practice or
trying to rob a store like there was
there was no in between you know i mean
yeah yeah you know because you know i
think that um
i've always liked scary adrenaline-like
situations where i
it's like you know where it would hit my
receptors in my brain that would excite
me you know that's why i love stand-up
so much because
you know performing because it it it
ignites certain things within me you
know i mean
yeah at that you know as a youngster as
well
you know so um so yeah i got kicked out
usually because
of not attending school but
but i was doing shady things you know i
mean
that they weren't privy to got it
yeah uh let's pull up your other picture
um okay so
now we have we have a shirtless pick
yeah
you have suspenders we've got a bandana
so again like
a fashion flare yeah
i look like i'm smuggling illegal exotic
fruits
you know in the black market or
something you know yes yeah right
yeah i mean it's definitely um there's
definitely an allure
here uh so what age about
was this picture this picture was also
um i was sober i think i was a little
older maybe i was 18.
i think this is the end of my senior
year
in high school so did you after college
did you go
do the college thing or were you like
after the high school you were like i'm
done i i went to junior college
you know but tonight for like three
weeks and i just
decided i just i can't retain any
information maybe i had a dd or i needed
some sort of medication at the time
but again this is the 1990 91
right so um yeah so after about
three or four weeks of junior college i
never went to school again
and did you just go right into stand-up
after that or was it like
a journey then what happened was um
so i i stayed sober so i got sober when
i was 17 and then when i was 23 i was
still sober
and i was um working a jobs like you
know restaurant jobs
coffee shop jobs and then one day i was
at a
aaa meeting and i shared
it was a big a meeting in san diego and
i crushed it
and and and i didn't even mean to crush
it but like i was like
sharing something about my life but
people were laughing like loud
man this old man at the a meeting pulled
me aside and he goes
you should try stand-up comedy i guess
it's too scary you know and then what
happened was i was walking down the
street
one day and there was a sign at the
comedy store in san diego
help wanted and i knocked on the door
and i got a job there as a bar back
door man and that's how it started
that's amazing
i'm seeing this um this thread in your
life that's sort of like
in the absence of a healthy
father relationship you have all of
these like older men kind of swoop in
and give you important guidance
and like put you on some kind of path
that you need to go on that got you
where you are now
i believe that there are people in my
life in my personal life
that have um given me
messages you know i mean or direct
notes even strangers and you know for me
i listen to things you know i mean and i
and i always think that things happen in
a cosmic kind of a way
right so it's like when that man told me
he pulled me aside and he said you
should do stand up
you know instead of going this is a
fluke i think i always think
this is a sign from the universe you
know i mean to send me
direction right so i don't ignore things
like that and also
um you know i'm afraid of a lot of
things but i don't really give a [ __ ]
what people think of me
and was was teenage bobby like that too
or was
no you were very sensitive but i think
you know
with being i couldn't get any girls even
in my early 20s
and also you know i was financially
struggling i just
even the jobs that i had it was just i
didn't have any money in the bank
there was just no future you know and so
i got kind of
desperate and in that desperation and in
that poverty
i think something happened where i went
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore
you know i have to i have i have to do
something
drastic you know i mean to survive in
this world so
um so that's why i did it i think that's
a perfect segue to
the final question that i like to ask um
on this podcast so i feel like we've
gotten into so many things and like
this question can obviously go very
heavy but if you were to
talk to your teenage self today oh my
god
what message would you have for him
it's not your fault there's nothing
wrong with you
you know you were just born into a
family that had a lot of like
violent you know and i just
it's not literally not you being
molested is not your fault
you did nothing to ask for that and um
it's going to work out for you man and
your life
is going to be so big and you're going
to travel the world
and you're going to meet all kinds of
people
and you're going to live a full insanely
great
life but you know hang in there
something like that that's beautiful
that's amazing bobby thank you so much
for coming on the podcast
was absolutely wonderful uh
and yeah and until next time everybody
this has been the rest of your teenage
self podcast
bye bye everyone
you